Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast from Mine Day,
June 15th,
2015.
And I'm back in the United States.
So United States of America and Danny
pigs in a blanket.
Yeah,
I'm back.
I'm back in the United States.
And uh,
immediately I started putting on weight when I got back here.
Cause this is something,
I don't know what the fuck is going on with their food.
Okay.
You know,
you remember a long time ago they had that book,
you know,
eat like a,
why you eat like a French woman,
be as skinny bench bitch like the a fucking chick over there in Paris,
whatever the,
whatever it was called,
the secrets of being a skinny bitch and Paris when a,
you're drinking your juice in the hood,
whatever the fucking,
whatever the book was called.
[inaudible] it has nothing to do with it.
Their food is as of a finer quality.
And uh,
you know,
they're constantly having legal battles with WHO's those fucking evil con?
What the fuck is his name?
The people own the food,
you know,
Mona Sant or something like that.
Not Jesus Christ.
And I know this Monsanto,
a four k more Tony months saying,
are we owns all the fucking say Jovi.
Um,
yeah,
they're constantly fighting and being like,
look,
if you want to have your fucking genetically altered food over here,
you have to put it on the label that is genetically altered and these cons won't
fucking do it.
Evidently.
Allegedly.
That's what I'm hearing.
Um,
now I'm also hearing that they sue organic farmers,
like they fucking plant their food next to,
uh,
you know,
the property next door to the organic farmers.
And then when the bees like cross pollinate,
then they sue the fucking organic farmer for fucking having some of their,
uh,
I dunno some of this shit and their food,
I don't even get out of that works.
It's like,
well what were some of my organic stuff being some of yours?
This is like a Reese's peanut butter cup here,
but they're bigger.
So they,
so,
um,
and then they fucking win.
So anyways,
all I know is um,
if they really have to watch what I eat in my own country and is sad cause I
want to eat like a fucking animal like I did overseas,
you know,
and I can still walk around and be a skinny bitch and Paris while drinking the
juice in my hood.
Is that asking too much?
God bless America.
Okay
land that I love.
And those people like talk their way through a song cause they can't sing
anymore.
Stand beside her and guide her through the light.
But tonight up above band,
still playing like Dat,
Dat da Dat,
exact front of mountain dew,
the prayers,
God bless America.
So a little Virbrato with some point.
Um,
I'm going to dumb ass mood.
I'm still a little jet lag.
It's four 53 where I'm at right now.
I'm probably going to wake up my neighbors because when you live in La this
year,
that close,
you're that close to your neighbors.
So right now my next door neighbor,
she's probably lying there going like,
who the fuck is talk singing.
God bless America.
I got as high fuck hang five 53 and the morning,
I know my wife Watches that show with the ladies there whose dad is now a woman
and a,
you know the ones out there in Kappa Alpha,
you know,
the way they fucking talk.
I was sitting there,
you know,
and this is,
this was a pivotal turning point in me getting along better with my wife was I
just gave into reality TV and I,
you know what I mean?
I just dialed into my fucking inner Caitlyn Jenner and was just like,
all right,
I'm going to fucking,
I'll feminine it up here,
right.
I'll tuck the package between the fucking,
I'll duct tape my balls and Dick to my tape for the next fucking hour and I will
sit here and I will watch this or shit.
So I'm watching it right.
And uh,
the big one there as j law had caused her the power forward of the Kardashians.
All right.
She's driving the mere cap one and then the one who's married to the fucking a
Kanye West.
The always humble Kanye West.
Right.
And,
uh,
did drive and over just cause she's trying to figure out,
you know,
if the fucking or whatever,
if this BlueEdge made it to the fucking
hanger area.
Sorry,
I'm not trying to get on medical and you guys,
she's trying to see if she's pregnant or I,
what the fuck's going on?
So the driving to some SUV there in Wyoming,
right?
Because that's what rich people in California do.
They eventually,
you know,
want to pretend that they're ranchers.
So they buy a big,
they buy a spread out there in Montana or some strong and long story short,
they're driving in this fucking SUV,
right?
The power forwards behind the wheel is j law had calls her,
the mere cat is in the fucking passenger seat and a else blue jeans in the back,
right?
So they fucking,
uh,
it's snowing in.
This truck goes by,
you know,
the truck he has like the wind or whatever you know,
is,
it goes by.
So,
uh,
you know,
James Worthy,
there is fucking,
you know,
Whoa,
go and look what the fuck.
And then they keep talking and Blahblahblahblahblah and then another truck goes
by and next thing you know she lost complete control of the car.
It as it's spinning,
right?
A woman in the back,
I think she's pregnant.
So she's freaking out.
Oh she's got a baby there.
Cute little baby is sitting there,
you know,
reading the fucking paper and they start spinning.
So the one in the back,
the mother is going,
hey,
fucking,
uh,
you know Orlando wool rich,
what the fuck?
What's going on?
And as they're spinning,
the woman behind the,
the,
the fucking wheel is God is no,
I fall,
it's not my fault.
It's all my fault.
And they fucking,
they spun into oncoming traffic luckily,
or not hit all right.
And then they fucking went off the road into a ditch and the big one,
the captain,
captain fucking Kirk took no responsibility whatsoever.
Was just like,
yeah.
And was actually mad at old splotchy back there cause she was upset with her.
She's going to add,
I mean,
as I,
I was Jack handed by when and it,
it blew me into some black ice.
It's like,
no,
you were going too fast.
You were driving too fucking fast for those conditions.
You lost control of the car with your niece in the car.
You fucking dope.
Right.
And nobody held their feet to the fire.
Okay.
Nobody gave her an instance like you,
you are a fuck up.
Yeah.
You know,
just standing there with your fucking back of your head,
touching the top of your back,
trying to talk to her,
get torn and getting a grill right.
Staring up from her navel,
looking between her teddies seeing a half or two nostrils,
just yelling out,
hey,
you fucked up lady.
Right.
None of them said that.
And then they just like the dare fucking just standing there going like,
Eh,
when my giant eight foot sister last [inaudible] it was like so sky,
like they always like build up to a fucking point.
He like,
yeah.
And,
and,
and it's always just say hi.
Okay.
And this media came down at our house and it slammed in to the roof above my bad
route.
Uh,
half a second I thought I was going to die.
I was like so scared.
So I am standing up pacing in the living room now.
Like the fucking,
I dunno,
some fucking pissed off coach who's trying to stay inside the coach's box so he
doesn't get a technical and I'm fucking screaming at the TV like a bad call was
made completely forgot that I was going to sit there and try and get along with
my wife by watching this horse shit.
And I'm yelling at the TV.
I'm like,
no,
you fucking eight foot can't you fucked up.
You were driving too fast.
Fast.
My fucking voice.
Crack it.
You'd have it too fast,
man.
You fucking nations in the car,
right?
Slow the fuck down.
You driving a four wheel drive vehicle.
You fucking dope.
Oh my God.
Don with that show.
That was it.
I tried.
I lasted fucking one clip.
I'm done with that show.
Fucking done with that show.
I fucking hate when people do shit like that and people call them on him that I
thought kind about about yeah,
it was your fault.
It is your fault.
Stop being powerless.
You Moron.
Alright.
You have total control of that fucking situation.
You just drive a little slower,
you drive a little slow.
Um,
anyways.
Anyway,
I shouldn't be making fun of them.
You know what they're going through right now.
What they're having to deal with,
you know,
lefties,
white,
black gays,
my up and down his back end.
Why inside out Doda Dad and now Bruce is fucking Kaitlin.
Right.
I really,
I really hold farm on that.
That people can not get upset with anybody in that family.
If this is still a little fucking wigged out that dad did,
dad is now their mom.
You know what I mean?
Just exactly what is the average time it takes,
you know,
for you to fucking get your head around that,
I dunno my white shit and going out.
He's shown his fucking Teddy's to his kids.
It's just like he's doing what I,
I mean,
I don't know.
Is that true?
If that's true,
I don't give a fuck.
That's just wrong and all kinds of levels.
You know what I mean?
I know.
I get it.
You're coming back from the mall and you got a little la shop shopper's high
going on and you want to show what you got,
but the tits,
right when you were guided,
you take your balls out and shown to,
no you didn't.
You don't do that.
You don't show you sexual goods to your fucking kids and then compile it with
new sexual goods.
Right.
And it's not like new and improved like,
Hey,
I've got my dick and large.
No,
I fucking,
I got some debts now.
Would you like to see them?
No,
Dad.
I mean,
mom,
I wouldn't,
Jesus Christ.
Kaitlin,
can you put your fucking new tits away?
Is that asking too much?
You're already took all my rouge.
Now you're going to take your tits out.
I mean,
I'm sitting in a car and I shall as power.
I was like Sam Scott or you took,
you have techs out dad.
It was like Thai sky.
Okay.
I was like,
is my dad taking his Ted Tower?
Right?
Yeah.
I was like Bruce,
I mean Kayla.
I mean,
what the fuck?
Jesus Christ.
You know what I mean?
You think you have enough?
Dude,
I haven't been having the week.
I don't know.
You haven't?
No.
You haven't.
You been having a nice regular fucking time.
I got news for you.
You've been having a time.
That is yes,
that is right.
Is fucking rain.
Do you want to stand me?
Well
anyways.
What are some of the other shit that people want to,
uh,
wanted me to talk about this week?
Um,
I don't.
Oh,
here's what another thing I don't understand.
Like I get the kids being freaked out by Caitlin.
I get that.
You know what I mean?
I get that they need some time on that.
What?
That makes total fucking sense.
What I don't understand is people flipping out about this white chick who said
she was black and everybody's going,
she's actually white.
She's saying she's black.
She's got odds are fucking Tana Dude.
And she fucking kicked up a,
Hey,
what the fuck?
Like I,
this is what I don't understand.
Who gives a fuck?
I don't give a shit if she says she's Portuguese,
I don't care.
That's what the fuck she wants.
I don't give a fuck.
Okay.
You want me to go?
It goes back to Bruce Jenner.
I don't give a shit that he wants to be a woman,
but I mean,
you got to understand people got out.
Whoa.
Oh,
it's going on here.
You know,
you gotta give you gotta keep people a couple of weeks
bros.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Katie.
Do Kolby Kay.
It's Caitlin.
I all right.
Sorry.
Sorry,
Kaitlin.
Um,
okay.
Anyways,
yeah.
This white chick who said she was black,
right.
Um,
the only thing I think was fucked up on of all of that,
Rachel was her name,
which should have been a dead giveaway.
Have you ever met a black woman named Rachel and I got righteous.
You look so dope today.
I got right.
Jill came out and she was like sad fly.
Um,
all right,
Rachel Dolce Dolce Dolezal.
Now that sounds like a black woman's name.
Her last name.
She should have flipped around.
She says she should've been Doughlas owl.
No,
though is there,
I don't know how to say it.
Anyways,
racial,
whatever 37 was pictured outside of her home Friday for the first time since the
scandal
erupted over her misrepresentation of a race.
This is what people are flipping out about.
Not that are fucking food is a,
you know,
I dunno.
Whatever the fuck they do the ship,
they don't tell us.
Um,
genetically altered baby seals washing up onto the fucking beach is fuck all of
that.
There's some chick from some fucking God forsaken place pretending to be black
when she's actually white.
Let's focus on this.
Uh,
um,
she also responded to her detractors in a new interview saying,
what I'd like to say them is that don't give two shits about what you think.
I liked that.
There you go.
You got girl.
Um,
she then added,
I do consider myself to be black.
Her parents revealed Thursday.
This is the only thing that I thought was,
was fucked up.
All right.
Are Parents revealed Thursday she started disguising yourself as black in 2007
and no longer speaks to them because they will ruin her.
Image is chick is out of her fucking mind.
But in,
in the long and short of all of it.
Who was she hurting?
You know what I mean?
It's as far as a white person's goal.
Could you be any more involved in bettering race relations?
She killed off the white person.
It's side of her.
Right.
She's working at the Naacp.
We what,
what more she got to do on some level.
I mean she could have just been some privileged fucking a white chick driving
around in a fucking SUV and they are,
I was like sigh.
All right.
She could have been that.
Instead.
She does all of this shit about,
I don't understand like cutting off your fucking parents.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
I wonder if she called him crack as you cracked.
He's got to stay away from my black ass,
my newly black ass.
Cause you're going to ruin my image.
Um,
she,
she has been a civil rights activist in Idaho.
That's not an easy gig.
I remember a long time ago,
a comic I know was working the funny bone up there and the Klan was fucking
having a demonstration in Boise and he called up the club.
He was black by the way,
and asked for a ride over and they wouldn't give it to them.
And they were like,
why do you need a ride?
It's a quick walk over.
He's like,
I'm cause I'm black in the clan is having a fucking rally.
You assholes.
And then the club was just like,
and I got,
why are you being sad?
Difficult?
Um,
so she was an activist and uh,
Idaho,
uh,
she's,
she also teaches African studies that eastern Washington University and that's a
little bit fucked up.
You know what I mean?
I think she can report on it.
I don't know if she can teach about it right now.
Maybe it gets,
if you read up enough on it,
you can teach the class.
I have no idea.
She is facing a city ethics investigation after identifying herself as black and
an application to serve on a local police ombudsman commission.
What the fuck?
Ombudsmen.
I,
you know,
I've been speaking the English language or at least attempting to
for 47 fucking year on budsman
definition.
Anybody know?
Does anybody know,
oh,
am budsman an official appointment to investigate individuals complaints against
maladministration,
especially that of public authorities?
See,
this is why I don't look upwards.
Now.
What the fuck is maladministration
well,
administration,
I have to go to the today to investigate my maladministration.
My flow was not where it needs to be.
Sorry,
sorry.
The menstrual flow joke.
What do you want from me?
Um,
anyways,
so she's,
uh,
I dunno.
Facing all this shit.
Rachel,
don't Dole Zelle does that all the White Naacp leader,
oh my God.
How much shit is she gonna get
like now because she's done what she's done.
When you see her,
everyone's just going to be like,
hey,
why is trying to drive him nuts
at cracker?
How get mother fuck,
um,
when [inaudible] is,
this is the fun part here.
They actually interviewed her son.
We asked,
you're saying,
uh,
what race are you?
And she's like,
um,
I don't understand the question.
And the guy's like,
what race are you?
Okay,
Rachel,
whatever.
She also gave an interview about the controversies saying of our detractors.
I said that already one press further about her race.
She told K,
r e m I actually don't like the term African American.
I prefer black.
Oh God.
And I would say that if I was asked,
I would definitely say that yes,
I do consider myself to be black.
You know what?
I don't understand this.
You know,
if Bruce can consider him or herself to be Kaitlyn,
why can't fucking uh,
Debbie here consider itself to be a,
uh,
Desiree?
Whatever the fuck you want to call her.
I don't know.
Dacia um,
oh my God.
Look at a parents.
Jesus Christ.
Then you're extremely white.
Yeah,
they're so white.
Her Dad's name is Larry.
Although wait a minute,
Larry Johnson played for the Knicks,
but anytime I hear Larry,
Larry,
to me,
he's a white guy.
Larry Bird,
Larry,
Jerry,
um,
Larry and Ruth Ann.
Oh my God.
Pictured speaking to CNN on Friday had revealed their daughter Spokane's NAACP
chapter president is white,
not African American.
They actually have her fucking birth certificate.
Oh Man.
Oh Jesus.
You know,
what is she,
what the way she's done her hair,
she kind of looks mixed.
Although when she was,
uh,
when she was a little girl,
she looks like she was on the Olson,
the Olson now the fucking little house on the prairie.
Hey,
did anybody see that fucking article?
I'm on Lionel Richie and Gq magazine.
Um,
you know,
at a nine hour flight I fucking grabbed every magazine out there,
right?
Gq magazine,
such a stupid fucking magazine by the way.
They got some decent articles.
But what was funny was some guy in there just ripped rolling stones to shreds
because they fucking,
you know,
had the,
uh,
that rape story that ended up not being true and how they didn't investigate it
saying all this fucking horseshit and saying that,
you know,
I don't even understand why people took it so seriously because I,
oh my God,
like rolling stone hasn't been relevant forever.
Right.
And it's in literally in that Gq fucking magazine they got,
who's that tennis star from fucking Russia,
the fucking nine foot blonde who wasn't as good as Serena,
but she makes more money cause she's blonde.
And blue eyed,
right.
She fucking,
uh,
they got a,
she's,
she,
she's going to drive some new Porsche,
right.
And the,
all the quotes that they're using is that she's fucking totally into speed.
She likes driving like a maniac and she's a car person.
So I'm like,
wow,
this girl's even hotter now.
How fucking hard is it that uh,
that uh,
uh,
some beautiful woman likes to get behind the wheel of a Porsche and just fucking
see how fast it can go.
And the quotes they using is leading you to believe that that's what the fuck's
going on.
And then you read the article and it's like a one page article and she's like,
it's like,
I like to go fast,
but I have too much to lose by maybe in another life.
You know what I mean?
That's what it was.
And you're sitting there talking about journalistic integrity as you suck me
into this fucking magazine because I want to read about the new Porsche and this
statute was fucking blonde.
Likes to drive it and like 200 miles an hour.
That's the way you sold it.
Yukon.
And it wasn't that
okay.
I don't know.
I don't like that fucking magazine because the ivory,
everything in there is like a fucking $30,000 watch and you're supposed to own
like a plane.
Like that's supposed to be the thing that I'm going for.
It's like,
what am I fucking James Bond?
Like who is this magazine for my a spy.
I hate when they have fucking pictures too.
Right.
And they have a celebrity and they're fucking in casual clothes and then
there'll be like,
you know,
fucking uh,
you know Eddie,
Rick Shaw here is where is wearing a fucking $900 tee shirt,
buy a whatever.
That's fucking stores.
I always think it's herpes.
Fermi's Ar Mez,
right.
Kind of a fucking jerk off.
Uh Huh.
Why would you do,
you know,
wears a pair of fucking $900 million,
I dunno,
whatever.
So I'm off,
I'm totally off the beaten path.
I there this chicky or wants to be black.
I mean,
she should fucking be a,
her and her parents need to fucking work on their relationship.
Maybe they can just treat her like she's African American.
I have no idea.
Like God knows I live in Idaho.
They probably wouldn't let her in the house.
They could use the back door and shit.
Larry all Matt.
Yeah.
You want it to be black
who's out is you are not invited over for Christmas and come over and clean up
if you want.
That'd be fucking hilarious for parents who are actually fucking racist.
And then they start,
this is like a Chappelle show skit waiting to fucking happen.
Um,
so anyways,
yeah,
they got it.
They could definitely got to repair some stuff there.
I don't know what's going on with his fucking lady.
Uh,
yeah.
I Dunno know.
She likes to go Tannin.
She likes do a fucking do her hair up and uh,
yeah,
and I'm wondering is if you see the car she's driving,
she's definitely a white chick though.
Jesus Christ.
What is that?
What the fuck is that thing?
It's one of those things that isn't a van.
It isn't an SUV and it isn't a car.
You know those things,
whatever you call those things.
Gmcs almost whatever the fuck it is,
I don't know.
All right,
whatever.
God bless her.
God bless whatever the fuck she wants to do,
you know?
Um,
all right.
What do you go from here?
Where do you go from here?
You know what you do?
You read a little bit of advertising.
I think that that's the move to make here.
I definitely think that's the move my white freckled ass.
Think that's the move to make here.
All right man.
Great everybody.
Attention Grill masters.
If your father is a man of exquisite taste,
there is no longer,
there is no finer gift then the ultimate steak house experience.
Right.
And his very own backyard.
The man.
Great.
A hundred percent cast iron grill grates the man.
What's a man great.
You might've not asked man.
Grates are American made high quality 100% cast iron grades that sit right on
top of your existing greats weighing in at eight pounds at pace.
Man.
Greats insured juicy,
tender meat grouse with no flareups and perfect cmax every time.
Man.
Greats patented design delivers steakhouse quality flavor right at home.
Uh Yeah.
Cause if you also have to cook it,
you know what I mean?
Steak House.
Not only is it steakhouse quality,
somebody else cooks it.
Take advantage of the Monday morning podcast,
Father's Day special,
and get 40% off all cast iron grates and premium brushes@mangreat.com when fans
used to code burb Bu Rr 21 per 21 everybody spend 50 bucks or more.
This father's day with man,
great and dad were received a premium United States of bacon tee shirt.
Oh Gigi is.
Don't forget the brush man great is designed their long bristle brush to get
down deep between each rail,
keeping your grades and prime grilling condition.
No more dead carcass between the grill grates now with the man.
Great fucking bristle brush or them by Monday,
June 15th for guaranteed arrival by Father's day.
That's today anywhere in the United States.
You got to buy it today.
Everybody Click on the Fucker,
get you dead something.
Don't be a cunt to make sure to go to [inaudible] dot com and enter my coupon
code [inaudible] at checkout.
All right,
and here we go.
Me,
me,
Andy's me undies.
No more sweaty balls,
but due to do me undies me undies.
Now my dad has some tits put 'em on and the fuck in mall,
your tank stays dry and that's not all.
They even keep the clams nice and dry.
Even if he getting fingered bang,
Oh yeah.
If you got on the Andy Panties,
90% that's the percent of your life that you're in your underwear and underwear.
It gets old fast.
You know that feeling of putting on an old pair of saggy underwear,
your balls just twisted in the breeze,
you know,
and all of a sudden you just don't even feel like getting out of bed.
You don't feel like getting out of bed if your balls aren't being cradled.
How can you walk into your boss's office and say,
listen there fuzz face.
I want to fucking race.
Who says so?
Me and my snuggled ball say sell.
You grab out his letter opener and you stick it to his neck.
You're not going to do that.
If your balls hanging in the breeze,
you're going to feel vulnerable.
You need to know the feeling of the great fitting underwear that is two times
softer than cotton Jesus Christ.
You need to know about me undies,
Dotcom,
me undies as the most comfortable underwear you will ever try on,
and it's insane how good they make you fucking balls field.
They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on you.
They literally pull moisture gross away from your skin.
She stay cool,
but they also make you look great.
It's going to be no reason to wear pants anymore.
You're just going to walk down the street.
Hey ladies.
Hey ladies,
look at these snug fit balls.
Oh yeah,
get on your fucking knees and rob them.
I really mean it.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and check out the photography you fucking pervert.
And for the ladies,
checkout those smoking hot boy shorts,
but you have to try them on for yourself.
Nice and slowly too.
Sorry.
This quality would typically retail for two times to me.
UNDIES,
price,
no meat,
no retail.
Middle Middleman means more savings by you.
Here,
I'll make it easy.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr and get 20% off your first order and low
flat rate,
international shipping
and save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee you're going to be happy with them or your,
uh,
your first pair is free.
Once you feel me undies on your body,
you're never going to go back.
Just walking around all day,
slightly aroused with a silly smile on your face.
It's going to get you places and me undies isn't just for you guys.
They launched their all on me.
Why not take all of me?
Can't you see my clam is nice and dry.
High.
Pau Ko,
the women's all in me collection.
They four piece line of undies designed specifically for the female body in all
of its complex,
gorgeous has hell glory.
Um,
why don't they say that about men while we're not gorgeous,
they make statues with the guy's junk hanging out.
Right?
But to get that 20% off,
you have to go to me undies.
Mondays,
Mondays dot.
Fucking calm.
Oh yeah.
[inaudible] dot com slash bird.
That's m e undies.com/barb in the last read from this chunk and this chunk I
should say trunk club.
Everybody.
Guys,
you might hate shopping but you still want to look good,
right?
What is a man to do?
What if you could snap your fingers,
hey and have a trunk full of clothes that fit perfectly and make you look
amazing.
You're gonna love what gets delivered to you from Trunk Club.
And if it don't,
you can just send the shit back and be like,
Hey,
trunk club.
What the fuck was that box of shit?
And they're going to be like,
we're sorry.
We'll send you a new trunk@trunkclub.com slash bird you answer a few simple
questions.
You're more on about your look style and size.
I like to look good.
Then they assign a real person who helps to stallion cause you're not a real
person cause you're too dumb to sharp.
They email,
they email you a list of close.
Hey Dad,
away from my ears,
the email you will list to close.
They recommend sending you.
This is fucking great by the way.
This is like you're a celebrity.
You got your own stylist.
Hey this is what I like.
Go get it.
Alright,
you approve.
And at no cost to you.
They ship a trunk full of fresh,
new,
close the door.
Well I would hope so.
I don't want to want to be used.
Try them on.
Keep what you want.
Send back what you don't in their prepaid box.
That said a better wardrobe than you could ever pick out your self.
Evidently in minutes that I mentioned the services free.
How could they do that?
Well they just jack up the price of the clubs.
You stylists the shopping the box,
even the shipping,
all 100% free.
How do these people make money?
When you go to trunk club.com/burr only pay for the clothes.
You keep.
No ongoing subscriptions,
no hidden charges,
no malls,
just great clothes.
Handpicked for your style.
Um,
you're gonna,
you're gonna thank me on this.
Provided you get close you like and right now it's completely free.
So go get started@trunkclub.com slash bird today.
That's trunk club.com/burr.
He should definitely do that,
man.
I would think,
cause I've learned in the last like six months that um,
when you actually dress nice as much as your guy friends break your balls,
fucking women love it.
And I don't mean putting on a nice goddamn shirt.
All right.
I mean just,
you know,
every once in awhile you break out a pocket square,
the,
the level of shit you're going to in a sport coat,
the level of shit you're going to take from your friends will easily be balanced
out by the amount of fucking women that will just pack.
All right.
God,
I like that look good.
Yeah.
Oh,
what's going on with you?
All right.
Cause they slowly dropped to their knees.
I carbo.
Alright,
next thing you know,
you're getting blown.
Least that's how the fantasy works in my head.
My head,
my head,
big fucking white freckled head.
Oh yeah.
All right.
Do you see that fucking lady yet?
Who yelled at Lebron?
He's walking off the court after having a fucking professional team on his back
for 82 games in four rounds of the fucking playoffs.
You know,
going headfirst into a camera and even needing stitches,
finishing the game like a fucking hockey player.
You'd think that he'd get respect even though it is fans of the other team,
even though it is in a way game or whatever the fuck it was,
wasn't a way game.
I don't know.
I don't pay attention.
So He's walking off the court and some lady yells at them.
Okay
something like 10 feet away.
Well I did like to be a punk ass bitch
and I love the security.
Just goes watch your mouth lady.
What's your mom?
A woman watch your mouth.
Watch your mouth.
Woman and Lebron just stopped and glared at her and I can't tell cause everybody
did so many mishmash is of the video.
I believe she went,
sorry.
You know what is wrong with people?
I that's one of my favorite moments in sports is when some asshole in the crowd
yells something cause you know they're looking at him like they were a cartoon.
All right?
She wouldn't have said that shit to a regular size.
Lebron.
Forget about what is Lebron?
Six seven six eight six nine.
The guys literally a giant.
You guys are doing this with my fucking voice this week.
Um,
I just love when he just stopped the fucking glared at him,
but you know what I mean?
What do you,
what would you expect from a sports fan from California?
All right.
They,
they are the worst.
I am a huge sports fan and it's depressing how bad sports fans are in the entire
state of California.
The all they,
every fucking thing they say ends with the word bitch.
This is our house.
Bitch.
What bitch?
Okay.
Fucking Dodgers bitch.
That just the fucking,
they're the fucking worst.
They don't know a fucking thing about the game.
And I know there's going to be a bunch of people being like,
I know about the game.
I'm just saying generally fucking speaking.
All right.
Like listen,
if you actually said,
hey bill,
you're from Massachusetts and every time they pan into the crowd,
that is delta.
Those are some of the ugliest collections of human beings I've ever seen him in
my life.
I would not argue with you all right?
And I am part of that.
If I was in the crowd too,
I would cause you to recoil.
I always see it whenever they go.
Whenever they pan into the crowd at Boston,
I'm always like,
Jesus Christ.
Look at those people.
Look at him fucking animals.
Right?
But I'll tell you something about those animals.
They know the game and they could talk the game.
So can fans in New York.
Oh,
all these posts.
They can fucking talk the game.
People in the Midwest,
great fucking fans.
Those maniacs down south again after it,
they can talk about the game.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
This state of California,
you know what's up?
NBA Finals,
bitch.
This is our house,
Hey Lebron,
your punk ass bitch.
I don't get it.
Everybody sounds like they're in one of those awful car movies,
right?
The fast and the furious and 24 seconds.
Get that car out of here.
All those fucking movies,
gumball,
rally,
all of them.
They all sound like they're,
they'll,
everybody sounds like they're on fucking MTV cribs.
I don't understand it.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know what caused it.
Was it reality television?
You know what I mean?
Reality Television.
They had this formula where they would always have nine annoying white people
and then,
uh,
somebody black and they would stick them in there and then eventually the black
person lost their fucking mind because they live in with nine white people the
same way as a white person after a fucking while.
You know what I mean?
The black person is sitting there and you know,
listening to James Taylor in the background,
I mean,
how long do you expect somebody black to have to deal with that before they
fucking flip out?
You know?
And I just think watching them screaming and yelling,
I noticed over the years,
all of a sudden,
like the fucking white people on the show,
they,
when they would flip out,
they started yelling at the way the black person yelled.
It was,
it's been a real weird thing.
Like when you,
regardless of your background,
you know what I mean?
You could be like,
you know,
the widest,
like,
Oh,
I gotta I gotta I got called.
That's how I kind of already hang on.
It's like fat.
Now all of a sudden if you are on a reality show and you got into a fight,
you'd be like,
what's up bitch?
This is my house,
Bitch.
You fucking head would be rolling all around and shit.
I don't,
I don't fucking get it.
But anyways,
fortunately the only place in um,
sports fandom that that is seeped into is the California sports.
Can't sports fan the fucking worst?
The worst.
I will say though,
every once in a while when you meet a California sports fan that actually knows
the game,
it's one of the great,
it's one of the great fucking moments that you can have in the state.
Like,
I stopped going to sports bars.
I stopped.
Like if I go to a game,
I don't wear any sports paraphernalia.
I just don't,
I don't do,
I mean look at them like what the fuck they did out here?
They fuck God damn dodger fans.
You got a dad with his,
with his kids,
beat him to the point where he's permanently brain damaged
fucking baseball bitch.
That's just,
I don't get it.
Don't fucking get it.
So it doesn't surprise me that she said that.
I love that Lebron stopped and glared at her and she was able to be like,
oh,
that's not a fucking hologram.
That's actually a real person.
Hologram the right word.
I was like halfway through that sentence,
don't say it built.
Don't saying I'm going to try a new word.
I hope it's right.
So anyways,
um,
the fucking,
uh,
Golden State Warriors,
I actually watched the game and then watch that kid there with his chew toy is a
little pacifier coming out of his mouth every two seconds.
I don't give a fuck.
Then he does that and it drives me up the fucking wall.
That's,
that is one of the greatest shoot as well.
Time.
I was actually sitting at the bar with a buddy of mine and he was saying that
guy,
he's the greatest shooter in NBA history.
And I was like,
Whoa,
whoa.
Hey,
oh,
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
I know he's having a hell of a year.
I know he's had a hell of a couple of years.
I said,
listen,
all right,
Larry Bird made players from the opposed,
he was having a game,
he was shooting so well,
players on the opposing team,
when he hit like his 50th fucking three pointer of the game,
it seemed they fell off the bench.
Okay.
The coach of the other team had to scold his players to stop cheering on this
guy who was killing them on the other team.
All right,
so out of respect for Larry Legend,
I don't respect for Kobe Bryant.
I haven't ever seen a guy,
okay.
Have two or three guys hanging on him from beyond the arc and do a turnaround
jumper and it fucking goes in more than that guy.
However,
how I will say this,
if curry plays at this level,
okay.
For the next like for five years straight without a doubt is the greatest shoot
I've ever seen in my life.
I had never seen a guy hit threes the way the guy gets threes.
Um,
okay.
I mean I like Larry Bird,
Reggie Miller,
they've,
they've had those games,
but it just,
this guy is like unconscious every fucking game.
I've never seen anything like it and watching Lebron carrying this team.
I mean,
I'm not always,
you can tell us as you can tell,
I don't really know this fucking sport,
but like watching what that guy's doing with that team,
man,
putting that team on his back,
dude.
Like just how much second,
remember that guy a few years ago,
he was like,
I didn't want the ball at the end of the game and now he's just,
he's just fucking beast.
And for that fucking lady to be at,
what's it like to be a punk ass?
But what the,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Okay.
Oh,
I wish she turned around with to walk away and he took like is eight foot arm.
It just reached in,
grabbed the back of her bra and what right.
He couldn't have done that,
what a,
her flying over eight rows.
But if ever it would have been deserved,
I would think so.
And um,
I have been watching the Stanley Cup final,
the Stanley Cup final,
um,
the NBA finals,
Stanley Cup final.
Um,
okay.
You know,
I actually think that somebody corrects me on that every fucking year and I'm
always just like,
I'm just at that old age now.
I'm just like,
oh,
um,
I've been watching that one and uh,
I think the Black Hawks winning that game five just won the series going back to
Chicago.
That's really not,
I'm not going out on a limb,
but there's that amazing thing when you see a truly great team that's gonna win
a number of championships there ability to step up in the moments and their
ability to know how to win a game that's lost.
They stole that fucking game.
Five.
No,
no.
They didn't know what to tell them.
They stole that game four was even when they still think they stole game four
game file game five was one of the fucking tamp just kept fucking up on their
own end.
They fucking,
the goalie and the defenseman run into each other.
They looked like peewee hockey and they had so many giveaways in their own
fucking end.
I just,
I dunno,
I bet as a Tampa fan,
your heart had to sink when that fucking happened.
Considering every Goddamn game has been a one goal game.
That the fact that you give up an easy one like that,
you must be thinking that that's like being down like three goals in this
series.
But anyways,
it's been an amazing thing.
And if,
uh,
if uh,
Chicago wins three in the last six years,
man,
I would say that they are the new Detroit Red Wings and I mean that is a highest
compliment because the red wings had that run for like 10,
11 years where every time you thought,
you know,
there's stars like,
okay,
Eisenman's getting older,
right?
This is done.
They just have that next fucking superstar step in.
And um,
they just fucking knew how to win.
And uh,
I don't,
I,
I'm a big fan of dynasties I like,
I like seeing like,
um,
I don't like this team was the next year this team wins.
Next thing,
this team where it's like you,
you need,
you need dynasties.
So you have like that,
uh,
those timeless players,
you know what I mean?
Like as much as people,
you know,
who will play against the Blackhawks all the fucking time.
Say like Vancouver fans will probably hate the fucking black cocks,
right?
Or Minnesota fans,
St Louis Blues fans.
As much as you hate him,
you got it.
You got to admit,
even now,
Jonathan tapes.
So he's the fucking man.
He gaffed I'm gonna give a fuck.
I don't give a shit.
If you bleed you fucking team's colors.
Did you just,
okay.
Yeah,
there's no way you went under.
So anyways,
I'm going to watch that game tonight and I actually think that,
um,
Chicago closes them out.
However,
I am going to be rooting for Tampa because I don't have a dog in this fucking
fight and I don't want the hockey season to end.
I'd like it to go seven games.
Um,
and by the way,
I think this is the been the best NBA finals and Stanley Cup finals,
like in the same year,
in a long time.
And it's been fucking great.
So I'm glad I'm back in the country here where I can actually watch the shape.
Um,
and speaking of which,
oh,
am I going to go to Vietnam?
I can go to these yet.
Did anybody see Hillary Clinton's fucking speech,
which she went up there dressed in Democrat.
Blue.
Okay.
Oh my God.
At the risk of burning a bit,
cause I'm definitely going to talk about this,
to sit there and watch her talking about rich people when her and her husband go
to that Bilderberg fucking meeting every year where the world's richest fucking
people,
most powerful military people and most powerful political people all get
together and decide how they're going to carve up the country,
the fucking world.
This year,
she's at that fucking meeting and she's sitting there talking about the working
man as cafe.
If you guys can't work,
oh,
whatever the fuck.
She said,
yeah,
you guys some jabs and everybody's like,
Yay.
Dumb little flag.
Yeah,
I don't.
She's literally making fun of the Super Rich.
It's like Hillary,
how are you going to get into office?
You were a senator.
What does that pay?
A couple hundred grand a year.
This fucking job costs a 100 million to get,
okay.
Costs 100 million to get to then make like 400 grand a year as president.
Right?
How the fuck you going to get that job from what regular Joe's $25 contribution
to your fucking campaign
or these fucking cunts.
The rich,
the exact rich constant you're talking about is how you're going to be fucking
president.
You're going to all,
all of them favors and you're going to do exactly what the fuck they tell you.
So you can get a second term and then in the end when you're fucking
presidencies over,
you're then going to go around the country and give speeches for $1 million a
night.
Nobody's worth a million and night,
but you're going to get paid $1 million a night and you're going to go right
back speaking to the people who put you into fucking office and they're going to
give you $1 million is they don't even fucking listen to you,
right?
Because they don't give a fuck.
All they're doing is washing their bribe money and food and I,
okay,
if you can't fucking see that and you're going to sit there and vote for a
Democrat or Republican,
I can't,
I can't even have a fucking conversation with you and you people who sit there
and say,
if you vote for the Libertarian fucking guy or whatever that you're throwing
your vote away.
I it,
you're not,
you're not all you're going to get,
it doesn't make a difference.
Who wins the Democrat or the Republican.
You're going to get the exact same shit fucking sandwich.
It might be a little to the left,
a little to the fucking right,
but it's going to be the exact same shit sandwich because those rich cons to
have money on both horses.
So no matter what they win.
Right.
So the fucking,
if you vote for somebody outside of that,
all you're doing is encouraging more people.
Yeah.
That there's hope that you can maybe somehow undo this fucking situation.
I Dunno.
I actually think that it's,
it's fucking over.
I don't think that it's,
it's possible.
You know,
it's so fucking depressing though,
to watch people once again,
once again,
I'm going to sit there and listen to a candidate who's a Democrat or Republican,
make these stupid ass fucking promises and they lose their fucking minds
thinking that it's actually going to change their lives for the better.
You know,
I,
I don't,
I don't know.
Sorry.
I know that's fucking super depressing.
That's just what I think.
So anyways,
let's get into the,
uh,
the questions here for the week.
All right.
And if you listen to these questions,
I'm going to get Joe [inaudible].
Yeah.
Um,
all right,
French listeners.
Hey Bill,
I thought I'd let you know we appreciate your acts and think you're doing a good
job.
I live in Paris,
France.
Oh Shit.
Look at this.
And yes,
you're right.
We're mostly assholes to people whether they come for France or abroad and I
don't think you guys are assholes.
You guys treated me Nice.
Uh,
currently with a couple of friends.
I currently am with a couple of friends,
having a good time listening to your ranch last jokes and since had been
following you for a few months,
I said to myself,
let the guy know you enjoy his jokes.
Well,
I appreciate that.
So they have it.
You have to come to,
you have some French Listener,
idiots over here that enjoy your show.
Please keep it up.
Have a drink with some French people at some point and go fuck yourself at
another.
Well,
I'll tell you,
I,
I'm gonna do a show in France at some point.
Actually,
you already talked to my,
um,
to my agent about it.
Um,
okay.
There was a theater over in the,
uh,
these see salary,
these mall,
um,
I think it was called the Odi on the Odr on theater.
Okay.
Does it stop?
Call the EOD on,
on the metro.
This is a theater,
the Odi on theater in,
uh,
in Paris and Gay Patty.
Um,
there it is.
Odi on theater.
It's a fucking 800.
How do you say that?
How do you say 800 in French and French
wheat
[inaudible] disorders.
Wait a minute.
I remember.
I fucking see song splits on that is I don't fuck,
I can't fucking remember.
Um,
do,
do you got to listen to French talk radio?
I love that cause over here when you listen to the English ones that go in like,
um,
to,
to do what she needed to do here.
Don't you see?
You have to,
um,
uh,
like you know that fucking dragon and as you're trying to come up with your
thoughts,
right?
Put your thoughts together over there.
They go like,
yeah,
who's your buddy?
It was all blue.
Blue,
blue.
Do,
do,
do.
It's fucking telling you you smoke a joint.
You listen to that shit.
You're going to fucking laugh your ass off.
Um,
so anyways,
the audience,
yes.
Daddy,
that op is,
it's located at DOL rule cornea in the CSERIES,
these mall of Patty on the Left Bank of this sen next to Luxembourg garden.
Um,
ah yeah,
I know where that is.
I just love that.
It was originally built between 1779 and 1782 right back before particle board
nailed guns.
Took you a little while to build something in the garden at the former hotel,
dig Dante to a neoclassical blah,
blah,
blah.
The theater was inaugurated.
Wait a second,
this is what I love here.
It was reopened in eight.
It burned in 18,
18.
Everything fucking burned down back then.
It was all made out of wood.
You didn't have any fire hydrants and some jerk off comes in and drops his
cigarette down.
Separate booth,
right?
Throws the fucking thing down and all of a sudden everybody's just like ruin
feel lives.
Right?
And the whole thing fucking burns down.
They got the Bucket Brigade trying to pee on the fire.
Then they just like God dammit.
Right,
let's rebuild it.
Then they start all over again.
This is why they weren't in great shape back then.
The building and rebuilding of shit that burned down and they're fucking food
wasn't g uh,
genetically altered.
That right there.
That is a recipe for a six pack.
So anyways,
that is my goal.
I want to do a show there.
Neo has already given me shit,
you know,
cause I'm a fucking workaholic and she's giving me shit going like can that just
be like the one city where you know,
we just hang out.
You know,
we have some us time,
which she's so fucking right,
but I'm a guy so I'm going to fuck that up.
I thought I finally got it.
I think I finally get being in a relationship and
how to keep a woman happy,
believe it or not.
Um,
I think I finally get it.
I don't know how to explain it to you cause it's like embarrassing because it
involves feelings and listening and being respectful
and all your women right now who went like you see,
that's a two way street.
All right?
It's a fucking two way street.
So anyways,
um,
I don't give a fuck.
I'm still going to play over there.
Come on man.
To have a show in Paris,
if ACDC,
complainant,
Paris,
you know what I mean?
They can't,
you know,
there's no fucking way I can sit there and not want to play that place.
I love ACDC.
You know,
bon Scott,
one of his last fucking shows he plays in Paris.
I gotta I gotta fucking,
I don't give a shit of Carol.
Ron People fucking show up.
Right.
And I'll give a fuck.
I'm going to do it.
I'll be like,
look,
it's one fucking show.
It's one show she'll give and she's a sweetheart.
Um,
so anyways,
that's nice.
I guess I actually got some letters here from people and from France and they're
actually helping me with my French.
All right.
The French correction from a lady.
That's fucking great.
Hey Billy boy,
I'm,
I'm listening to your last Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast.
And I have to correct you about your French insults.
Oh,
by all means.
I don't want to be like Roman Moroni.
You fogging best judges.
That's a fucking twit question.
The next one,
are you fog a nice toasted something.
Remember that?
It's going to have his fucking bells as far good bells in a sling.
You corked sucker.
Jesus the math and that guy.
Um,
Roman Moroni is one of my favorite characters of all time.
It's in a Johnny dangerously.
He's an immigrant and he,
uh,
he has a potty mouth,
but he mispronounces all the curses,
so I don't want to,
I don't want to be the Roman Moroni of,
uh,
of uh,
France.
So anyways,
she says,
I'm listening to your last Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast just before Friday.
You and I have to correct you a bunch of French insults.
If you want to say fuck your mother.
We usually say Veronica Tom Mayer.
I'm really nervous about n I Q.
U e r like that could be like,
I could accidentally say the n word there or say something homophobic because
the end kind of looks like queer.
Nick were
funny.
Quit man.
You gotta help me out.
Can you sound spell that so I don't fuck it up.
Say That instead of bus.
There is preferred here,
um,
about,
this is bullshit about something.
A better translation will be,
uh,
say say della married.
This is shit.
I like that better than this is bullshit.
You getting right to it.
Say Dad,
I mad.
Hey Jack.
Say Dale and Matt.
Um,
say data math.
rather than saying,
say Song Day con Connery Connery can be,
can be employed.
When you want to say to someone,
what you say is bullshit and the translation is to rent,
to recontact aid.
They con Ra.
I know,
I stink.
I got to get the Rosetta stone here.
Uh,
and,
and the last one,
uh,
employed.
Very employed in France.
We'll see.
Look at that.
Trying to get their fucking up the English here.
I guess this means used a lot in France.
Um,
it's best aid.
The Canard Open saying that first word right,
which I'm probably not.
When the person in front of you was the biggest asshole that you've ever met in
your life,
what does it mean canard?
Is that pig you fucking pig.
That means you're an asshole.
Oh,
there's two n's.
I Dunno.
Well thank you Sabrina.
Hey,
by the way,
you guys,
anybody French listening to this?
If you can help me out with anything.
Just like a new one alone.
Bruce share.
We're going to brunch.
I learned that yesterday,
right?
We were going to go to brunch cause I had like,
you know,
I'm trying to fucking be a better husband here so I'm just like,
all right,
this is your ESPN sports zone.
Let's go to fucking brunch.
And I'm,
oh my God,
what a shit show Brunches,
the dumbest fucking thing ever.
Let's go to breakfast when everybody else is going to breakfast so we can all
you just,
you just see these fucking people as you drive it over there,
all these breakfast places,
but you're not going to them and you just see all of these people just standing
outside,
sitting on benches,
staring at their fucking iPhones.
You know what I mean?
And breakfast is the easiest fucking meal to make.
You can't scramble up some eggs yourself while your wife makes some pancakes.
You can go make yourself a grand slam breakfast.
You guys could sit around,
right?
So he's got the orange juice,
she got some music playing and guess what?
There's a table.
The kitchen table.
No waiting,
right?
But at some they want to do,
I want to fucking go out and everybody look at their outfits.
Everybody look at the fucking outfits.
Um,
so anyways.
All right,
so we've got one from Manchester,
England here,
Manchester,
England,
Bill.
I'm a big fan from across the pond as you Yankees.
You'd like to say a not Yankees.
Yankee.
Oh,
calls Yankees.
Alright,
I'm red sox.
You understand me?
I was wondering if you,
I was wondering if you ever consider film and especially say he's preferably in
England.
Thanks for the laugh.
She can't even fucking hear me miserable
or that thing used to go Dell make me laugh.
Every count I don't face.
Um,
what I ever considered doing a special overseas.
yeah,
I was actually considering doing one in France,
just doing it in French and just put in the fucking thing out and then I could
actually do the same one in English somewhere else.
I'd have two different fucking specials.
I wouldn't give a fuck if a bunch of them English speaking countries saw the
French one.
They not even going to know what I'm talking about because they don't speak
French for the most part.
And that's the way we get a little two for one there.
You know what I mean?
Right there.
Like right there.
I,
the way I'm thinking comedically is I am thinking the way home depot thinks.
Like how can we take those two employees,
make them one and get the same job done and we make more fucking money.
That's what I'm doing.
You know,
I'm being a bit of a being a blimp,
being a little cheeky.
Um,
when I consider doing one over there,
um,
I dunno,
I don't know if I get you guys enough that,
uh,
that I would do that.
I would,
I would tell you this though.
I really enjoy doing one last,
last time down south.
I think what everybody seems to like to do is to get in front of their own
people because you don't want to get heckled or anything,
but I think there's some fun that is lost when,
uh,
you stand up in front of a room,
that's all you,
you know what I mean?
I think you want a little back and forth.
Personally,
I've always enjoyed,
you know,
people yelling out to me.
I don't,
I'm more,
I don't give a shit if somebody yells out to me.
I mean if you just being an asshole and just trying to disrupt the fucking show,
obviously that's annoying.
But I say a lot of stupid shit on stage so it doesn't surprise me.
You know when I'm talking about the wage gap that some woman yells at me when
I'm in the crowd.
And then to be honest with you,
I really want to hear what she has to say cause I'm trying to learn something
about it because I don't have to deal with that shit.
And the only way that I can hear that is through my own fucking manners.
So it's good to hear her fucking perspective.
So I don't consider that a heckle.
I consider it a conversation.
So getting back to that to go to England,
I would probably say some shit deliberately to get you guys going because what's
the fun?
What the fuck is the purpose of me going over to England?
If I'm not going to give you guys a little bit of Shit and then you give me a
little shit back and then we all fucking laugh.
Right.
So maybe that could be a good idea,
sir.
That might be a good idea.
I Dunno.
I would,
I would definitely consider it.
I would consider it,
you know,
I'd run that up.
The flag pole.
All right.
Let me do the last little bits of a advertising here and uh,
and then I'll answer your last questions you guys can get on with your life.
All right.
stamps.com everyone making trips to the post office is becoming a thing of the
past.
You just don't need to do it anymore.
Thanks to stamps.com you're already know that going to the post office is
inconvenient.
Yeah,
but you know,
if you're into collecting stamps or if you want some cool stamps,
you know what I mean?
If either one of those nerds,
you know,
if you're into that and like birdwatching,
you probably still go to the post office,
but for the rest of you,
you already know that going to the post office is,
is that,
that's a nightmare.
Totally inconvenient.
Driving their right standing behind the person who is trying to send a muffler
out in a fucking envelope,
right?
You don't want to be there finding parking,
wait in the line.
The whole damn thing,
which you probably didn't know is you're paying more for postage there.
Then you have to stamps.com is the better way by in print official US postage
for any letter,
any package right from your computer,
a printer.
Then just hand it to the mailman.
A Ella,
you skippy.
Thanks for not shooting me by,
by postmen.
Uh,
with stamps.com you'll get special postage discount.
She can't even get at the post office on FirstClass priority mail international
and more.
Never go to the post office again.
Hey everybody.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters,
all of my posters for my tours.
Uh,
right now,
use my last name [inaudible] for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale and up to $55
free posters.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
[inaudible] and by the way,
fall you guys who ordered the autographed posters,
they've all been there,
there been put in their tubes and they're being shipped out this week.
Um,
I want to thank everybody for buying those,
getting those out of my house.
I still got a few more leftover in some box,
but uh,
I have some leftover posters also from um,
my run of 19 shows at the,
uh,
at the Wilburn Boston and uh,
got a couple hundred of those leftover autographed,
all of those and we'll probably in the next month,
but those back up on the website,
um,
just so we can get it,
we got to get all the other ones shipped out first.
All right.
If you wondering where your poster is,
it's the way.
All right,
legal zoom,
everyone.
There's a lot of great reasons that Smart People Trust,
uh,
legal zoom for starters,
if you want to incorporate form an LLC or nonprofit file,
a patent or a trademark,
get a DBA and more legal zoom provides the help you need over the past decade
more than a million businesses,
business owners,
just like you,
hip started with legal zoom.
But did you know that legal zoom is also your first step when you need advice
from a first stop when you need advice from an attorney,
legal zoom is not a law firm,
so they built a network of independent attorneys in most states to provide legal
advice and other useful services to help you run your business.
So whether you need a contract reviewed or advice or whether you should
incorporate or form an LLC,
whatever you legal question is,
start with legal zoom.
And as always,
they provide complete transparency with upfront pricing,
customer reviews,
and a hundred percent satisfaction guaranteed.
Make this match choice.
Go for your business.
Make the smart choice for your business@legalzoom.com today.
And don't forget to enter Burr at checkout to save even more.
Again,
that's bur bur at checkout for more savings,
legalzoom,
Promo code,
burr legal help is here.
Um,
and lastly,
but not leastly.
If you'd like to donate to the podcast and it won't cost you anything,
next time you go into amazon.com to buy something,
swing by Bill bird.com first click on the merchant page,
click on the Amazon link.
It'll take you right to Amazon.
It doesn't cost you any extra money.
They just kicked me a little,
a little something,
something for fucking driving traffic to their site.
All right.
Do it if you want to.
If you don't,
I understand you're a busy person.
You don't have that time to be doing extra clicks to you.
All right,
let's get on with the last questions here.
Dilemma.
Billy Bird.
Would you rather play 15 seasons in the professional sport and wind zero rings
or when one year,
rookie year and suffer a career ending injury the next oh,
Jesus.
Uh,
no.
I'll take the 15 seasons,
I'll take the money and put the rest on a gift certificate.
Now I would rather,
uh,
as much as you want to win a championship,
there's also playing for the love of the game,
you know?
And there's also a,
I think,
I think most athletes would choose playing 15 seasons because you want to play,
you know,
y'all self,
you're going to fuck up your body.
I don't want just one fucking,
you know,
what kind of contract did I get my rookie year?
I mean,
if I had a shit contract and I was on that team and I got my ring and then I
blow out my knee the next year I'm working at the fucking,
I'm doing landscaping,
then people,
hey you,
you,
you played in the Superbowl and they'll look at your trimming hedges.
You know,
that would be a motherfucker,
you know,
I would take a while to get over that emotionally.
Um,
you know,
like,
I bet he,
you know,
what's his face there for the Broncos?
I at the game too,
when he suffered his career ending injury.
Um,
Tarell Davis,
I was at Dec ever tell you guys that I was at that game.
I was doing some college gigs out in,
um,
Colorado and uh,
as always I always try to build the road around something,
you know,
beyond just doing stand up.
So you know,
you get,
get a feel for that part of the country.
And one of the big things for me was always going to sporting events.
So this was,
they was still in Mile High Stadium.
They had just won back to back titles.
John Elway retired.
Right.
I always wanted,
he played one more year if they could have got three,
but you know,
to got hurt but would've Sharelle got heard of John was playing,
what did they have passed on that play?
Who knows?
Anyways,
so they were playing the jets.
Jts,
Jess,
Jess and uh,
that's when bill Parcells was there and he was building a monster and they were
going to win their first Superbowl.
They were favorites.
One of the favorites to go to the Superbowl at the beginning of the year.
So I,
uh,
you know,
when I saw that they were going to be playing the Denver Broncos in Mile High
Stadium,
like the fifth week of the season or something like that.
And Lo and behold,
John Elway's not playing.
It was supposed to be at this great fucking match up the Broncos.
We'll all win for the jets that year.
Uh,
Vinny Testaverde blew out his Achilles tendon the first game of the year.
And that's when Keyshawn cried,
right?
No.
Are you give me the,
um,
no,
that's my quarterback was that other guy that had a lunatic.
That's my waterbed.
You don't talk about it.
And that's by quarterback.
Um,
so the jets were owned four,
so it was too fucking,
oh.
And fourteens.
And I showed up and there was like nobody there.
The scalpers had a mountain of fucking tech.
I bought a ticket for fucking face value.
It could have probably got it for less,
but you know,
I'm not one of those people.
It's like I do,
you'll break even.
He ain't go give you a fucking money.
And I went to the game and um,
and that was the game that Soil Davis,
uh,
unfortunately one of the would have been,
I still think he is one of the great fucking running backs of all time and a,
I mean,
I'm a can't imagine what that guy had to go through emotionally after winning
two rings.
And just wondering what might have been,
I think despite winning the championships and knowing what that feels like,
I think the,
the equal to that high would be the low of what could have been.
And you know,
and when he's watching all of those,
uh,
greatest running backs of all time,
he's left off that list a lot because he doesn't have,
because what people do when those arguments is they immediately go to the
ALMANAC and they go,
all right.
Emmitt Smith has 17,000 fucking yards.
You know,
they look at Dickerson,
Walter Payton fucking Jim Brown,
Oj Simpson,
they go through all of those guys and they look and because their career numbers
are up there,
and then guys who got hurt,
um,
Barry Sanders,
who would I think is the greatest running back of all time,
the greatest one that I ever saw.
Um,
I would say the most complete I ever saw was Walter Payton.
I'd say the most devastating just of speed and power.
Yeah.
That was a precursor to Bo Jackson was Earl Campbell.
Bo Jackson was like a faster,
but I would say not as strong as Earl Campbell.
That's how big Earl Campbell was,
by the way.
Um,
Bo Jackson and Barry Sanders.
I would say those four were the best that I ever saw.
And,
but then as far as just effortless,
the greatest,
most beautiful runner I ever saw was Eric Dickerson.
Eric Dickerson didn't even look like he had to try.
He just looked like he was just,
he looked like he was jogging and it ain't,
it,
you couldn't even,
you couldn't understand why people couldn't catch up to him.
A man that,
that just makes me fucking,
I that,
that,
that was football back then.
I fucking,
I dude,
I,
that's the greatest thing I have.
Do you realize I grew up,
you know,
started watching sports in the late seventies and I got to see all of the late
seventies and the aids,
like the golden age of football was in the 70s.
I got to see the end of that.
And then the result of it,
the west coast offense,
air corps yell,
all of that,
Dan Marino and all those guys come of age in the 80s,
all those great running backs.
And meanwhile in hockey you had fucking Wayne Gretzky,
Mario Lemieux,
those great Edmonton teams.
Uh,
um,
the mystique of the Canadians was,
was still there.
Um,
I don't mind insulting Canadian fans like it just the big bad fucking Bruins.
They would just was fucking amazing.
Perfect amount of the greatest gold scores of all time.
Fucking Paul Coffee scored like 49 50 goals is a fucking defenseman was
unbelievable.
And then there was always a fight,
like every like period period and a half.
It was fucking perfect.
And then a basketball.
You had Larry Bird Magic Johnson that then went into fucking Michael Jordan.
This is just the fucking eighties.
And baseball was the one that actually kind of dropped off during that time.
But even though they dropped off,
you still had the wizard of Oz,
the Smith,
you still like Kirk Gibson's home run.
You still had the bash brothers in the Oakland A's,
right.
Yankees dropped off or whatever,
but it was still great.
Still still fucking great.
That's like the 80s might be the greatest decade ever,
if you will,
just to fucking sports fan and American sports to watch.
I'm arguing that right now.
I'm saying it might've been the greatest one.
It might've been.
Um,
all right.
Walmart.
A Billy birthday boy.
How,
why?
Yeah.
Happy Belated Birthday.
Thank you very much.
Just wanting to share with you what I believe to be the finest display of white
trash entertainment found on the Internet.
This video has gone viral and where I,
uh,
where I live and it's not every day you see two obese fat fucks duking it out in
a Walmart.
Um,
it's two women.
I've actually seen this,
uh,
this video and um,
let's see,
what does it say?
I'm sorry.
I was just making sure that it wasn't in mono again.
Headphones felt weird here for a second.
Uh,
this video has gone viral or around where I live.
Um,
the lady does bring her kid in off the sideline at one point,
so I guess we can call it a family outing anyways.
Just thought you'd have a chuckle and you and your podcast last Thursday,
June 11th was one of the greatest ones.
Thank you Jaime and stitches make you all right.
Thank you.
Um,
yeah,
I did see this and I actually loved,
I don't know what this says about me.
I loved that that little kid took out the shampoo bottle,
you know,
and was helping out his mom,
what is the kid supposed to fucking do?
Like that is exactly your mom's losing the fight.
You got to jump in there and save your mom.
I mean,
even if you don't love your mom,
that's your ride home.
You fucking seven years old.
So he goes to take the fuck.
He grabs a shampoo bottle due to,
it's like wrestling back in the day.
Captain Lou Albano comes in with a foreign object now in the ref,
didn't see it.
I guess people got upset because some were telling the kid not to do it.
And then one woman was saying telling the kid to do it and I agreed with her.
Cause if you're just going to stand there and you're not going to break up the
fight,
you know,
I dunno at that point I think everybody's guilty at that point.
I actually thought it was great and I actually thought that that kid could have
swung the bottle a little harder.
I would have liked to seen that kid get a little more torque.
He needed to twist his body.
He went more with like hammer fist motion,
which I understand cause UFC is really popular.
But um,
you know,
if he got one of those,
one of those baseball videos,
you know how to swing a bat correctly.
You know,
they broke it down to the three fucking movements.
He got that thing going on.
He would,
he would have knocked her out.
I just love that one of them drives up and like one of those fucking motorcars
cause they can't fucking walk.
So you thinking like,
oh,
maybe you have some sort of disease.
Maybe you're,
you're,
you're paralyzed.
I don't know what the fuck's going on with you,
but uh,
you know,
I respect that you're in that thing and I'm going to get out of the way.
And all of a sudden she fucking stands up like some preacher put his hand on her
forehead and churns out.
She's fine
and she's fighting and shit.
So it really came down.
That was the most fascinating thing to me.
It's like,
so why are you in that motorized cart?
I you just fucking lazy or you a genius because I got to admit,
you ever seen those motorized cars?
Those things can fucking fly.
And there is an expression why stand up when you can sit down.
Why sit down when you can lie down.
Why walk when you can drive,
you know,
all you gotta do is lay off the donuts and you're crushing it.
Um,
anyways,
I don't know what to tell you.
All right.
That's the podcast for this fucking week.
I'll put the link up for that.
Um,
I don't have any,
any crazy predictions for the finals.
I think that they're going to go the way that they're going to go.
You know,
I think Chicago's going to win the cup and I think Sacramento is going to win
the title and uh,
I'm happy for the fucking warriors,
men if they went and I'll be happy for the Cavaliers if they fucking win.
Um,
I really liked both of those teams,
both those organizations and stuff.
I just like him,
you know what I mean?
Neither one of us.
One in for fucking ever.
You really can't.
If you're a true sports fan,
you know,
you gotta be happy for either one.
Um,
and then as far as,
uh,
the Stanley Cup goes,
I'd love to see Tampa when,
cause I'm a huge Steve Eisenman Fan.
And um,
I just,
I said this before,
I just like Tampa in general.
I like the devil race.
I still call him the devil rays fucking pussies down there.
We started,
they have a range.
Does that mean we locked the Daryl?
Can we just call the Royce Lean on getting nerves?
Shit,
I live on a houseboat and clear all the Florida.
I'll just regular buy in.
I don't think,
I don't think for myself.
I think could be,
say a word that means is this Damon's going to come out not come right up on the
pitcher's mound and invite the picture on their clock,
a vampire and then,
and then he fucking has lightening coming out his fingers and we all turn into
Damon's and are never get to see my Lord,
my savior,
Jesus Christ.
Can we just call him the raise?
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Go Fuck Yourself.
And on Thursday out,
Jack.